Hello again, this
is Maria Plummer,
and this topic
is inflammation.
It is a little bit
complicated. Some of
you may have some
background knowledge
and may have heard
some of these things,
and I'm into
repetition. I believe
repetition helps, so
we will go over things,
and I will lead you
through the important
topics. I also wanna
say one thing. I do
a lot of bolding and
putting things in
red, and I do that for
guidance, But also,
I do not want people
to not notice the
things that are not
in bold or read, okay?
So please take
everything into
consideration, and
I'll tell you when
to get more detailed
and when you
don't need to be
more detailed.
So here are the session
objectives, which
are the same or
should be the
same on the CPG.
And here is kind
of the way we're
going to go with
this inflammation,
kind of a map of how
things happen. It
starts with acute
inflammation, and you can
use this if you would
like as we go along.
Also, you may want
to pause this session
halfway through just
to get a break here.
So inflammation in
general is a response
to cell injury. We
discussed cell injury,
and it's an early and
a transient response.
Why does inflammation
happen? Because
you need to eliminate
that cause of the
cell injury, localize
it, eliminate it,
restore the tissue,
whether that be a
bacterial infection,
a cut, or whatever.
There's going to be
a lot of chemical
mediators involved
and changes in the
vasculature and white
blood cell responses.
Again, when we
talk about cute, we
usually mean fast,
minute, hours,
those neutrophils.
In this case, chronic
would be slower,
days or longer,
things like monocytes
and macrophages and
lymphocytes. Monocytes,
by the way, are the
same thing as
macrophages but monocytes
are what we call them in
the blood's peripheral
blood and macrophages
what you call
them in tissue when
you see the word itis
afterward we usually
are talking about some
kind of inflammatory
process in the old
days latin ruled i happen
to like latin a lot
and um the cardinal
signs were considered
are still considered
rubor calor tumor
and the fifth one was
added later, functional
lysae. So basically
you all know this,
you know, when you get
a wound there's going
to be redness, warmth,
swelling, or edema,
and pain. And if it's
really bad you will
lose function of
whatever that part is.
What causes inflammation?
We went through,
you know, inflammation
is not always infection,
but infection
certainly can cause
inflammation. It's number
one on this list. But
also immune reaction
tissue necrosis, when we
talk about myocardial
infarction at some
point you will see that
necrosis will elicit
inflammation. Foreign
bodies, trauma, radiation
burns, and this is
not a complete list.
So again as we
discuss cell
injury this
is a response.
Okay so here are some
pictures. There's a
cellulitis of this
person's foot it's
very swollen you can
tell that it's red if
you were to touch
yours probably be warm.
And the inflamed
tonsil next is also
very inflamed and
endematous and red.
And probably these
are painful as well.
So these are, in
these cases, this
inflammation and also
infection probably.
Here's an appendix on
the right bottom is
a normal one. And
on the left, this is
an inflamed appendix,
not bad actually,
but you can see the
red vessels on the
surface. So that's part
of the rubor or the
redness and it is
swollen it is swollen
so this is probably
an early appendicitis
so here's the overview
how does now we're
talking about acute
information at this point
we'll talk about chronic
afterwards um you
need a stimulus then
there's a bunch of
vascular things that
happen in a vessel then
the cellular events
which involve the white
cells then let's say
it's bacterial or
even necrosis, you
need phagocytosis, the
digesting of whatever
it is that's causing the
injury. And then the
acute inflammation has
to end or else you're
going to have more
damage. And we'll talk
about all this. And
the inflammatory response
involves a lot of
R's here. If you want
to think of it that
way, it has to recognize
that something did
happen that's injured.
The white blood cells
have to be recruited.
Most of the time,
that's the neutrophils
and the macrophages.
And whatever it is,
microbial agent needs
to, or whatever,
needs to be removed.
And the response itself
has to be regulated.
It can't just go crazy.
We all saw in COVID
how the immune system
can go very, very
crazy in the sense that
it just overdoes it and
can cause what is known
as a cytokine storm
and we'll get a little
bit into that later.
And of course resolution
which is really
repair that is the topic
of the next session.
So this is just some
physiology. I am not
a physiologist but
just some basic things.
You know hydrostatic
pressure is what
pushes fluid out
whereas osmotic pressure
also known as
oncotic keeps fluid
in and these are
just visuals showing
that and you need a
balance in that or
you're going to get
basically edema.
And as I said that
when the balance is
disrupted you will
get edema. Now if the
hydrostatic and oncotic
pressures are not
an equal immune you
usually get what's
known as a transidate.
A transidate is low
in protein there's
not a lot of cells
in it and it has a
low specific gravity.
That's going to be
different than an
exudate, which we'll
discuss in a little bit.
If the hydrostatic
pressure is increased,
then you get
localized edema,
and that is seen in
the x-ray on top.
That's, for example,
someone with congestive
heart failure.
Now, I don't expect
you to recognize it.
It's not the best
x-ray either, but it's
a little too white
and fluffy, especially
in the bottom.
There's water in
the lungs. There's
edema in the lungs,
pulmonary congestion.
And if the oncotic
pressures decrease like
in liver kidney disease
then you can get
generalized dema or
what's known as anisarka.
So in malnutrition
this poor baby here
has kwashiorka disease
which you don't have
to know but this
is severe protein
malnutrition that's
usually in children and
it's usually found in
very severe cases of
starvation and poverty
stricken reasons.
So the whole body is
edematous here. And
so again, I want
to repeat, edema is
excessive fluid in the
extravascular space,
and that would
be swelling
or tumor in the Latin.
Okay, now these steps
are artificial. It's
not like one step
happens, it stops, and the
other step, we're
going to go through a
couple steps here, but
this is just to simplify
it and not that it
would be step one,
step two. But first
of all, when something
happens you need to
get to that source. So
there's vasodilation and
this picture shows it
and the mechanism is
that there's some kind
of trigger and
histamine. Histamine is a
very important mediator
that relaxes the
vascular smooth muscle
and I already mentioned
that increased hydrostatic
pressure causes
a transnate and this
vasodilation because
the smooth muscle
relaxes and the vessels
are made of smooth
muscle in the wall that
will dilate the vessel
and you'll get more
blood flow and that
contributes to heat and
edema or rubor and cholor
which is not written
here so a little
word i'm going to do
little um sidetracks
because a lot of the terms
i use you may not or
you may know already
but i just want to
um make definitions
known so i just mentioned
histamine and these
are this is made and
stored in mast cells.
Physical trauma can
elicit it and it binds
antibodies to mast
cells. Those would be
allergic reactions.
It's also part of the
anaphylic toxins which
are proteins of the
complement system which
we'll talk about later
and histamine relaxes
the vascular muscle
so that means the
vessels will dilate. It
also increases vascular
permeability and
we're going to go through
this. The other one
that's kind of important
is nitric oxide
which is produced by
endothelial cells where
it's a dissolved gas
and it acts like a
signaling molecule and
it also relaxes vascular
smooth muscle thus
dilating the vessel.
Okay here's a nice
table from Robbins.
I don't believe in
memorization but in
usage so So just to
keep everything kind
of organized, this
puts all the things
we're going to talk
about in a table.
I don't want you to
memorize it, but you
need to know that
vasodilation, the main
mediators are histamine
and prostagladins,
and I also mentioned
nitric oxide, and
we'll talk about some
of these, and these
are all very important
information. So I
don't really want you
to memorize it, but I
do want you to be
familiar and know if I
say something what it
what category it may
be and a lot of these
by the way overlap
okay they do more than
one thing so let's
talk about vascular
permeability uh we're
talking about how
leaky the vessel is and
when the vessel becomes
leaky uh it's going
to affect the
hemodynamics so the more
leaky it is that's
because it's got increased
permeability and
you can get then an
exudate. An exudate has
high cellular and protein
content as opposed
to the transudate we
spoke of in a high
specific gravity. An
example would be pus
or something or the
better way to say it
is purulent exudate and
it's full of white
blood cells, dead cell
debris, and many times
the microorganisms.
So again this is a
nice visual of what
can happen transudate
versus exudate.
I'm not going to go
through it bit by bit
but the point is that
you know the fat the
bigger the arrow the
thicker the arrow that
means there's increased
hydrostatic pressure in
B and you get a
transidate and we've been
through this low protein
low cellular content
if you have decreased
colloid osmotic pressure
also you would get a
transidate and then
the exidate what happens
is there's increased
vascular permeability.
As you can tell,
the endothelial cells
that are lining the
vessel on the bottom
have gaps in them now.
There's a thick arrow
through all of them for
them, and that means
things can leak out, and
that's what happens
to making the exudate.
So let's go to step two,
again an artificial step.
Once we have, you
know, dilated, then we
can, and again, this is
not like one stop and
then another. It just
kind of flows together.
vascular permeability
increase. The most
significant mechanism
behind that is histamine
again which retracts
the endothelial
cells so you get little
openings as you see in
this picture and that
would increase vascular
permeability so that
fluid and proteins
and cells can leak out
forming an exudate.
Okay so again
this is also other
things also
contribute to this but
I'm trying to simplify
it to recognize
the major players,
if you will.
This is an immediate and
a transient response,
15 to 30 minutes,
but nobody's going to
take a timer to it, but
around that. So what
you have these things
happening, vasodilation
permeability, and
that is going to lead
to, if you will, step
three of the vascular
changes. And that means
that blood flow is
going to be slower uh
like a like a garden
hose if you oh if you
have a bigger diameter
um and it gets permeable
you're going to
get uh slower moving
water so the blood flow
is slower and the word
for that is stasis
um and the mechanism is
as we've kind of said
already vasodilation
increasing the diameter
of the vessel because
it's now relaxed
um that's the hemodynamics
the transidation
which means decreased
fluid and higher
concentration of the
red blood cells so
you get the stasis
so the blood kind of
it's more red blood
cells and you lose fluid
as well with
permeability what happens
and this is important
is the accumulation
of white blood
cells especially
neutrophils and acute
inflammation along the
vascular epithelium
that should be
endothelium really not
epithelium but they get
displaced perfectly
and that is called
margination and this
is a picture of a
vessel a lot of red
blood cells in the middle
and if you can see
all around here on the
inside of the vessel
are blue little look
like squish dance as
one mentor told me
that's margination the
neutrophils marginate
I used to go on rounds
with an infectious
disease professor
who used to a doctor
who used to love to
say okay when we were
clogging up the
hallways around, she'd
say, make like a
neutrophil and marginate,
meaning get to the
edge of the wall
so people can move.
So that's one way to
think about it.
Now again, there is
overlap. As I said,
I've been talking about
histamine, nitric
oxide, which mediates
laser dilation,
increased blood flow,
and I am repeating
myself on purpose.
These things all
contribute to the redness,
the warmth, and
the swelling. The
pain also is because
the prostaglandins,
especially PGE2,
sensitives the nerve
endings to something
known as bradyokinin,
which does a lot
of things, not just
pain, but we burn
color as well. So let
me just take you
on a little trip to
bradyokinin, which are
vasoactive peptides.
Bradyokinin, as well
as prostaglandins
and histamine will
mediate vasodilation. So
the arterioles will
dilate, they release
nitric oxide or
prostacyclin, other
things, there's so
many that I'm not going
to go through them,
and that increases the
blood flow. The smooth
muscle is relaxing,
that increases the
blood flow. So rubor
and color or redness
and heat develop.
Now bradyocondin, as
I said, along with
prostaglandin E2 helps
sensitize sensory
nerve endings and
causes pain or dolor.
The bradyclining
causes veins to
vasoconstrict though.
I just talked about
vasodilation. Now
they vasoconstrict by
releasing prostaglandin
F2 and that will
then increase pressure
in the capillaries
as well and can lead
to leakage and you
get increase in
vascular permeability.
So bradyclining does
a lot of things as I
kind of bolded here
rubric collar paint
and vascular permeability
and you know it's
always confusing but
really kind of it
causes vasodilation
the low concentrations
and then higher it
works on the veins at
vasoconstriction but
it's mainly we need
to think of it as the
arterial vasodilator
now I mentioned
prostaglandin so I'm taking
another little side
trip just to define
this, not that you
need to know, but I
want you to, when I
say prostaglandins,
what am I talking about?
And you may already
know what I'm talking
about. But the
prostaglandins and
leukotrienes come from
the essential fatty
acid, linoleic acid,
and the release
from the membrane
phospholipids by the enzyme
action of phospholipids
A2. And this, again,
may be repeat.
Prostaglandins are
the arachidonic acid
mediators generated
by COX-1 and COX-2,
which you've
probably heard about,
especially in pharmacology,
causing vasodilation,
vascular permeability,
pain, and
fever. So this also
contributes to pain.
Note here, that's
why aspirin blocks, I
believe, one of the Cox's
here. So this is how
it works, and I'll
let the pharmacologist
talk about that more.
And then the leukotrienes
are mediators from
their arachidonic acid
metabolites generated
by different enzymes,
lipooxygenases, which
are vasoconstrictors
and also vascular
primitiva, bronchospasm.
We're not going to
talk too much about
that. I just, because I
mentioned prostaglandins,
I wanted to explain
it. So we've had all
these vascular changes
and now we have this
blood kind of
slowing down, edema,
margination. Okay, that's
great, but the immune
cells, the white blood
cells, need to go to
the site of the injury,
which is not going
to be necessarily inside
the vessel so we need
the white blood cells
to respond so this
is a neat way of looking
at it I didn't make
this up and I think
it's you know again
it's important not to
put things into very
strict categories but
this helps in remembering
that the cellular
response you know we've
had the vascular
response first mobilizes
the white blood cells
to get out of the
circulation to get to
wherever they have to go
to do their thing to
the site of cellular
injury. This whole thing
is mediated by adhesion
molecules and cytokines
which we'll talk
about and so if you
will the margination
that I talked about
and now we're going to
go into rolling and
adhesion are all called
happening within the
vessel lumen whereas
then we need to get out
of it and then we do
transmigration and
chemotaxis and we're going
to be talking about
each of these steps.
So how do we you
know we've marginated
and we need the white
blood cells to slow
down. Again I'm
using the example of
a neutrophil and a
bacterial infection.
This is an introduction
to cytokines and
basically cytokines,
and probably not for the
first time you've
heard, cytokines are
signaling molecules, little
proteins, and they're
made by cells like
macrophages and
activated limbs and they
basically modulate the
function of other cells.
And two major ones
you may want to keep
in mind are tumor
necrosis factor and
interleukin-1 which are
produced by activated
macrophages and lymphocytes
they are stimulated
by microbial products
immune complexes
physical injury any you
know things that
cause inflammation now
tnf or tumor necrosis
factor is was also or
is also called cachectins
for the word cachexia
it's very destructive
of human tissues
where you get cachexia
and many people who
have cancer for example
interleukin-1 is
called interleukin-1
because it was the first
one discovered and
it propagates the
inflammatory response at
a lot of different levels
and also significantly
affects T cells
lymphocytes so here's
another chart that comes
from Robbins and again
please don't memorize
it but as you can see
in acute information
TNF and IL-1 are
important and as I didn't
go into detail but
the principal sources
are listed you don't
need to know anyone
all of them but as you
notice macrophages are
almost everywhere in
the principal sources
and the principal
actions are listed in
the third column so
take a look at this and
we'll talk later about
chronic inflammation
so this is a really
really nice flow chart
again discussing
tumor necrosis factor
and interleukin one
and their local effects
and their systemic
effects, which I put
in a big red circle
because that's kind
of what we see in people
who have inflammation
and say an infection
of some sort.
So the local effects
include on the
vascular endothelium,
expression of the
adhesion molecules on
the white blood cells,
and we're going to
go through these,
but these are some of
the things they do.
They activate the
white blood cells,
produce cytokines, and
the fibroblast we'll
talk about more
in the healing and
repair session where
they proliferate, make
collagen, which goes
into scar production,
okay? But notice
that the systemic
effects, these two
are pretty important
cytokines because
they do affect fever.
Leucocytosis means an
increase in white blood
cells, usually neutrophils,
but acute phase
reactants are
reactants that go up in
inflammation appetite is
decreased if you've all
had the flu you know
that and sleep you
get very sleepy okay
so now we have the
margination and we're going
to go to rolling we're
going to slow down
the white blood cells
to get to where they
need to go and this
picture came from a
academic scholar a couple
years back and i think
it's really cool um i
never thought of it that
way but that's exactly
what's happening we
want to slow down
the white blood cells
and the big thing the
selectins are what
really are important here
the expression of selectins
on the endothelial
cells now it's important
to realize that
there's low affinity
adhesion molecules on
neutrophils and they're
called l-selectins
because that's sound
i think that's for a
leukocyte and endothelial
cells or e-selectins
neutrophils themselves
naturally express
it but endothelial cells
need to be stimulated
to express these
selectants so that
rolling can happen and
it is stimulated the
expression by or
regulated if you will by
tumor necrosis factor
interleukin one and
there is a binding on
this other molecule
or chemical and i don't
need you to memorize
that i just want you
to know the whole
general role of what's
going on so they've
slowing down and now
we need them to kind of
stop and adhere to the
inside of the vascular
endothelium so that
they're at the spot
where they need to go
but they're still inside
the blood vessels and
the way they do that
is using integrin so
selectins is for rolling
and integrins is for
adhesion keep that in
mind the mechanism of
adhesion is the activity
of high affinity
integrins again on white
blood cells and
endothelial cells. Now
integrin molecules
expressed on white blood
cells neutrophils in a
very low affinity state
so for them to work they
need to be activated
and things like C5A
which we'll talk about
it's a complement
protein activate them and
become they become
high affinity and here
come TNF and IL-1 again
for the macrophages
and that's going to
stimulate the expression
of integrin molecules
on endothelial cells.
This is a great,
great picture. I love
this picture because
it kind of shows in
visual what I've been
saying, that this
is a multi-step
process. This is the
white blood cell, the
big purple pink ball
there, and it's going
through the blood
vessel. So after
it marginates, we
need it to roll and
then become activated
to adhere to the
area, then it needs to
adhere. And then it
needs to cross the
endothelium by piercing
the basement membrane.
That's called
transmigration. Another word
for that is diapodesis.
And then it has
to get to where it's,
you know, the area
because it's not going
to be right there.
So you need chemokines
or chemoattractants
that come from the
injury to attractive.
So again, selectins are
important in rolling.
Chemokines activate
white blood cells to
increase the avidity
of the integrins,
and the integrins
are important in firm
adhesion. And then you
need transmigration.
And you see a whole
bunch of different
molecules here, proteins
that are listed.
And what I want you
to remember are the
selectins, the
integrins especially.
PCAM may come up later
on in your career.
But the important
thing is that it
doesn't happen by
magic, right? All these
things have to
work together with
mediators to reach
the destination and do
what they need to do.
So transmigration,
diapodesis, the
purpose is to get the
white blood cell
through the vessel.
And the mechanism is
the endothelial cells
are attracted and the
white cells go between.
This happens mostly
in post capillary
venules and the
chemokines simulate the
neutrophils that are now
adherent to inside the
vessel to get through
or migrate through the
gaps towards the
chemical concentration
which a gradient which
is the site of injury.
So they have to cross
endothelium they
pierce the basement
membrane and they
probably use of course
enzymes to do that
and that would be
something like collagenases
because that would
break up things
in the basement
membrane of the vessel.
Okay, chemotaxis, I've
been talking about
it. We just mean locomotion
along the chemical
gradient. White blood
cells follow that
gradient, and chemotactic
agents, there's a
lot of them. I put
them down in asterisks.
Some come from the
complement system. There's
arachidonic acid
metabolites, etc., etc.
Again, just realize
that There's a lot of
different mediators. And
signals from receptors,
and by the way, what
they do is they bind
to specific seven-member
G proteins coupled
receptors on the white
blood cell surfaces.
Signals from the
receptors cause second
messengers to
increase the calcium
inside the cytoplasm
and activate the
enzymes. We talked
about that in cellular
injury. and that
polymerizes actin and
localized myosin. If
you don't have the
actin and myosin, you
can't move, right?
You need that, and
that causes migration.
This is a very busy
slide, and I do not need
you to memorize the
complement system. I'm
sure if somebody else
will, I don't really
want you to. What I
want you to understand
is that the complement
system, and again this
is kind of a side um
track here uh is like
about 20 or more that
are proteins that
they're basically um
host defense against
microbes again we're
talking about a bacteria
for example the result
is important and that
is lysis breaking up
so they are activated
and with the activation
and each it's you
get this kind of cascade
and it was not as
enzymatic cascade okay
and the products that
come out of this of
the cleavage um are the
products that kind of
are important because
they some of them can
cause what we've been
talking about now
i've said things about
vascular permeability
there's a lot of things
that can cause it not
just one thing and
we're going to talk
about opsonization so
there's three pathways
again i do not need you
to memorize that somebody
will, but not me,
the classical alternate
lectin. But the whole
point of everything
is there on the bottom
in big letters in
red. All the pathways,
as you can see, lead
to C3 convertase enzyme
and that formation,
which splits into C3A
and C3B. And you see
it here in the chart.
The ultimate is the
C5B9, which is the
molecule that causes
the complex that causes
the cell lysis and
activation. So when you
say complement fixation,
you mean it's the
end stage of all this
cascade of all these
things, enzymatic
reaction, and ultimately
we're going to break
up or lyse cell
membranes, for example,
of a microorganism.
So the cleavage
products I mentioned,
some of them that
there's a lot, but
some of them that are
important, there's
C3A, C5A, sometimes
people put C4A,
stimulate histamine,
cause increased
vascular permeability,
evasion dilation,
they're also known
as anaphylatoxins.
I've been saying a
lot of things, and as
you can tell, there's
a lot of overlap here.
C3b is important
for opsonization and
phagocytosis, which we
have not yet discussed
and will. And the
big thing at the
end is the C5b9
formation of the membrane
attack complex,
which is what I was
trying to say in the
earlier slide, which
basically kills or
lysis the microbe.
That's the purpose.
Now again activation
results from
signaling pathways and
that's triggered in
the white cells.
We've got cytosolic
or cytoplasmic calcium,
the enzymes like
protein kinase C,
phospholipase C,
they're moving now,
they're activated.
How does the white
cell recognize
dead tissue or
microbes? And there's
a lot of ways.
There's receptors,
TLRs for microbial
products. There's
receptors for something
called N-formal
methylene. And then
there's the receptors
for opsins and
receptors for cytokines.
These are all
important so that you
know the white blood
cell doesn't wander
aimlessly once it's
gone through the
vascular endothelium.
It has to go to a
certain place via the
chemokine gradient.
It says receptor
for opsins and that
should be complement
proteins. I apologize.
Okay so after the
white blood cells
recognize the what
they need to do what
they need to
phagocytose if you will
there's three steps
in phagocytosis
and that is the
recognition which we
just talked about
then it has to engulf
let's say the microbe
and it has to kill
it it's not enough
to just engulf it
so this is another
good uh visual i
think about opson
opsonization uh opsonization
helps with
recognition basically.
Opsonins are attached
to a microbe and
here they look like
these blue rods
and that helps
the white cells
better recognize
them you know
kind of if you
will flagging them
and the neutrophils
have those receptors
for opsonins as I mentioned
in the last slide.
The major ones are C3B
from the complement
system but also IgG
and something called
mannospining lectin.
Now, this is what
normally should happen
in an infection, or
in a bacterial
infection, which is a
pathology. There is,
and I'm going to mention
this again, I won't
examine you on Bruton's
agammaglobinemia,
but that is the fact
in which opsins are
defective. And so
they don't recognize,
the white bloods do
not recognize what
they need to do. And
these people cannot
fight off infections.
So then we need to ingest
the organism
and engulf it.
So there's phagosomes
which fuse with lysosomes,
so you get
phagolysosomes. And again,
this is all going to
be dependent on actin
polymerization. You
need that. An example of
what happens if you don't
have that is something
called Shetty-Higasi
syndrome, where you
have a defect in the
microtubule formation
or function and you can't
form a phagolysisome
and so therefore
you can't engulf the
organism okay again that
is just that's an example
okay now we have to
kill it's hard a way
to say it but basically
a bunch of things go
through there's a very
busy visual but it's
basically what happens
the reactive oxygen
species are very
important what happens if
you go follow this all
the way down to the
bottom the big circle
there the phagocyte oxidase
activation of NADPH
oxidase oxidizes the
NADPH and the oxygen is
reduced to a superoxide
anion that these are
the reactive oxygen
species then you have
an important enzyme
called superoxide
dismutase which reduces to
H2O2 and then the white
cells if you remember
have granules in them
the neutrophils and
one of one of the
things they have in them
is myeloperoxidase and
that will combine with
chloride and convert
H2O2 to hypochlorite
which is basically bleach
which kills the the
bacteria in this case
so you can take a look
at this and go
through it and this is
basically how And I don't
mean you to, you know,
study it in such
detail that you need to
know that this oxygen
loses one ion. No,
you know, just
get the general
feeling of what's
going on here.
I want to talk a
little bit more about
phagocytosis killing.
Again, repeating myself,
reactive oxygen
species are made within
the lysosome. And you
have the phagolysisome
that can ingest whatever
you need to ingest
without damaging the
host cells. and how
do they damage cells
via membrane lipid
peroxidation, protein
modification, and DNA
breakage. There's
also an enzyme called
nitric oxide synthetase
which is nitrogen
-derived free radicals
which are all also part
of it and probably you
see in the picture.
Now lysosomal enzymes
which are in the
white blood cell
can cause tissue
damage. This is
controlled by other anti
-enzymes, antiproteases,
for example.
Another example or
two of what happens if
something in these steps
go wrong is chronic
granulomatous disease
when you don't
have NAPDH oxidase.
It's a genetic enzyme
defect, okay? And
basically, if you learn
about catalase-positive
organisms, they get
ingested, but they
don't get killed, okay?
And also, there's
something else called
MPO deficiency where
you have defective
conversion of H2O2
to hypochlorite,
which is an
increased risk for
candidate infections.
I'm just giving
those as an example.
Understand what can
go wrong if even
one step is amiss.
Okay, another, I
think I've put this in
twice, the mediators
of inflammation. Again,
take a look. Histamine
and prostaglandins
are important,
cytokines, chemokines i
haven't really talked
about platelet activating
factor and we have
discussed complement
and bradyokinin so this
is kind of a review
and again white
cells are important
especially macrophages
as you can tell now we've
talked about acute
inflammation so far
we can categorize them
in four broad categories
serous is an effusion
so cell poor cell
poor fluid buildup
so the example would
be a blister which
you see on top on that
person's finger that's
serous fluid it's
very it's straw like
clear it's watery you
might even get a
viral pleuritis in the
pleural cavity of the
lung and that's serous.
Fibrinous it happens
when there's increased
permeability and you
have more of an exudate
and then you get
fibrin deposition
increased fibrin and
the example of that is
fibrinous pericarditis
which is the second
picture down which is
a heart believe it or
not covered in exudate,
covered in fibrin
exudate. This would
happen in pericarditis.
Sepurative, that's
the other word for
purulent or *****,
is again exudative
and usually happens
with pyogenic bacteria,
things like
staphylococcus. And this
poor person has a
very bad pus-filled
lesion on their
hand. And when you
have it localized,
it's basically
called an abscess.
is a localization of
pus and it could
be in or outside.
And then an ulcer is
all the way on the
bottom. That's when the
surface of the tissue
is basically excavated
and that's because
the necrotic tissue
is inflamed and sheds.
Okay so we've come
to the point where
we need the acute
inflammation to stop or
else it's going to
get really damaging.
So what can happen?
Well, we can have
a complete resolution
of, you know, you
get a cut, it gets
a little infected,
and you put
some neosporin
on and it goes away.
This is a, you know,
complete resolution
would be with a
minor injury and
labile and stable
cells, which I will
talk about more in
healing and repair.
Or what can happen
is there's a lot of
tissue destruction
and extensive injury,
in which case
you'll be healing by
scar again for the
next session and or
you can go into
chronic inflammation.
Let's talk a little bit
now on chronic we've
talked about acute
enough persistent
infections okay things
that don't go away or
their prolonged duration
can lead to chronic
inflammation attempts
you know there's
tissue injury attempts
to repair occurring
at the same time again
I'm repeating myself
the tissue destruction
with attempts at
healing by connective
tissue replacement and
again this this bullet
point is a will be
talked about a lot in
healing and repair.
The chronic
inflammatory cells are
mostly lymphocytes,
macrophages, plasma
cells and to some
extent eosinophils.
Macrophages by the
way known as monocytes
in the bloodstream
are also known
as histiocytes out
you know when they're
in tissue. I just
put that in because
some books use the
term it's an ultram
histiocyte meaning
tissue cell
basically but it's
also it's a macrophage.
Chronic inflammation
can lead to immune
mediated inflammatory
diseases autoimmune diseases
like rheumatoid
arthritis and you can get
once you get prolonged
exposure to toxins
like asbestos for
example or chronic
inflammation that
causes atherosclerosis
these are all topics
for a second year,
you can also get
chronic inflammation.
So the monocytes and
the macrophages, again
the monocytes come
out of the blood, they
extravasate into the
connective tissue and
they transform into
macrophages. The important
thing to remember
is neutrophils come
first and then the
macrophages become dominant
cell by about 48 hours.
This is something
that's going to come
up again and again.
Now does that mean
at 48 hours all the
macrophages there all
the neutrophils are
gone no this is a process
so but the important
thing to remember is
macrophages appear
after the neutrophils
though you may
still have neutrophils
around tissue
macrophages can live
for a long time and they
help eliminate injurious
agents and help
also in making growth
factors again which
we'll talk about in
the next topic to cause
tissue repair. Now,
can you have acute
and chronic inflammation
together? Yeah.
Chronic inflammation
sometimes will show
neutrophils because
the organisms are still
there. Our mediators
are being produced by
macrophages and T
lymphocytes. And in fact, when
we think about viral
infections, we tend to
think that it's lymphocytes
that predominate.
they may be the first
cells to arrive in
that case it's kind of
a little weird so if
a person has a viral
infection usually and
you do their white
blood cell count the
lymphocytes will be higher
than their neutrophils
but and i'll say it
again in acute infections
especially bacteria
the neutrophils
predominate many many
ways that's because they
are the most common
cell in the blood if you
recall from histology
of blood uh they're
more numerous they respond
quicker to chemokines
and they come within
six to 24 hours and
they also attach more
firmly to adhesion
molecules they don't
last long they're short
-lived and will undergo
apoptosis which we
discussed within 24 to
48 hours this is a very
nice chart I think
comparing acute inflammation
to chronic inflammation
I urge you to look
at it I don't like
memorization try to
understand what's going
on um you know we uh
we have discussed some
of this and this is
just to help you organize
all the words if you
will and thoughts again
um i think this is
this is the one i did
in twice for some reason
um i just put in
acute inflammation and
chronic inflammation
in red just to separate
them too but i want you
to know this the tnf
and the il1 on top
okay just so to recall,
this is a neutrophil
lymphocyte and
macrophage. Okay, we
discussed this on histology
of blood. The
neutrophil is on the top
left. It's got
multiple lobes, about
four, and remember it
has granules in it.
The lymphocyte is right
next to it on top.
It's got a big nucleus
and a little bit
bluer cytoplasm, and
it's smaller. And on
the bottom is a
macrophage monocyte, I
should call it, because
it's in the blood,
it again has this
kind of kidney-shaped
nucleus, big, and I
always like to think
of it as like an
amoeba because it
kind of conforms to
shape, but you don't
have to think of it
that way, but those
are the way they
look under the cell.
We had discussed
T lymphocytes
and B lymphocytes,
so as a review,
remember that the
progenitor T cells
are in bone marrow
and they get
further developed
in the thymus,
that's why they're
called T cells.
TCR undergoes your
rearrangement and you
get cd4 helper and
cd8 and um the b cells
are produced in the
bone marrow under the
immature ones they
undergo an immunoglobulin
rearrangement to become
naive b cells and
they express immunoglobulins
like igm that's
for acute uh and then
again like i said
this is somewhat
repetitive somewhat um
you've had some of this
and we'll go to have
it again and again so
that's the nice thing
about medicine in a
way uh i was told by
my dean when i was in
medical school that
you know it's repetitive
and it's repetitive
for a reason because
all these things
it's not just a matter
you can't just memorize
you got to remember
when we go into
myocardial infarction
this is going to become
an important point again
about the inflammation
because it's
necrosis uh activated
there are different
macrophages just as a
reminder m1 and M2,
if they're classically
activated, that comes
from interferon gamma.
And again, this
is for chronic
inflammation, and
they secrete different
interleukins, like
interleukin-12.
The
alternatively activated
macrophages, or M2,
promote growth factors,
especially TGF-beta.
Now, TGF-beta is
going to become really
important in the next
lecture, because it is
a big a fibrogenic
mediator, and it's
important in fibrosis
and tissue repair, okay?
This is a chart kind
of saying what I
just said, but
again, for those who
are more visual, and
I am, I think this
helps put it more
into perspective.
I really need, I feel
interleukin one is
important. Remember
that interleukin 12
is for chronic, but
you don't need to
memorize all of them
okay one thing you will
eventually get to IL
-5 becomes is important
eosinophils but
right now just worry
about the overall
what's going on here.
More on T lymphocytes
cytokines from the
activated macrophils
recruit the lymphocytes
and the CD4-positor
or helper to
secrete cytokines and
that really depends on
the subset of the
T cells so TH1, TH1
helper cells produce
interferon gamma, which
activates macrophages
via the classical
pathway. T helper
2's subset produces
these interleukins.
And as you can tell,
IL-5 that I just said
is right there in the
middle and that
activates eosinophils.
And then there's Th17
that secretes interleukin
17. And that's also
important as well.
So there's many,
many, and the point is
the different subsets
are recruited. and
the lymphocytes and the
macrophages they work
bi-directionally and
by that I mean this
really gorgeous picture
I think of how the
monocyte activated
macrophage and t-cell
up here on the top
they they go you know
goes back and forth it's
not like one way and
I this comes from
figure 321 in Robbins
and I urge you to take
a look at it because
we're right now we're
going to go into the
formation of a granuloma,
which is, we had
discussed granulomatous
necrosis. Okay,
so look at this as a
macrophage lymphocyte
interactions in chronic
inflammation. Right
now we're in chronic.
So when we have
granulomas, which we
had mentioned, it's a
chronic inflammation and
it's an attempt to at
least try to contain
the offending organism
or agent, which is
going be difficult to
get rid of and one of
the big examples is
tuberculosis or
mycobacteria tuberculosis
macrophages process
and present antigen
to the helper t-cells
that interaction
produces cytokines
like il2 which activate
other t-cells and this
goes on and perpetuates
response by causing
secretion of
interferon gamma
another important one as
well that leads to
macrophage activation
macrophages become
histiocytes or yeah
they're called epitheloid
histiocytes and
giant cells and you
get a granuloma and as
I mentioned in the
past you can have a
necrotizing or a non
-necrotizing granuloma.
Necrotizing if you
look at it it looks
like cheesy material
so when you see
it grossly we use
the term caseating,
necrotizing is more
for microscopic.
So here are examples
of some granulomas.
On top is a
sarcoid granuloma
and that is an
immune response. Okay
so we've got a
sarcoid granuloma and
a tattoo granuloma
on the bottom.
That's a foreign
body when you
think about that
black stuff in there,
brown stuff,
that's the pigment
and the body is
reacting to it.
Sarcoidosis you have
persistent T cell immune
response. So the
granuloma again for
definition is really an
aggregate of macrophages
that kind of come
together and this is
chronic inflammation
they're transformed into
epithelial like cells
and they're surrounded
by a lot of lymphocytes
some plasma cells
and also they may have
giant cells which you
see in the next picture
again to reiterate
this happens when the
immune system attempts
to isolate something
foreign but it's
unable to eliminate it
so tuberculosis is one
big one fungi foreign
objects keratin suture
fragments you can get
a suture granuloma
meaning in the area if
it's too big it will
form a granuloma around
the suture this is
a very high power
picture of a caseating or
necrotizing granuloma
um this turned out
to be uh again a tb
infection and this
is like that big pink
blobby stuff on the
right that's just all
necrotic tissue um
it's the caseous
center the necrotizing
granuloma. On the edge
you see some giant
cells and other
chronic inflammation.
And a word about
eosinophils. When you
see eosinophils there's
a big blue arrow
pointing to one of
them. They're very red.
Think allergies,
asthma, and
parasites. We've
said that before.
They have granules with
major basic protein
that are toxic to
parasites. They also
cause lysis of mammalian
epithelial cells.
So they do help in
killing parasites,
but they also contribute
to tissue damage
and things like
allergies and asthma.
This is a high picture,
a high power picture
of a bronchus with
somebody who has
asthma. So they have
a lot of eosinophils.
Okay, so let's go to
some case questions,
which are just
general. But a 24-year
-old woman is nursing
her newborn baby,
and she has a tender
erythematous area
around the ******
of her left breast.
Thick yellow
fluid is observed
to drain from
an open fissure.
Examination of the
yellow breast fluid under
the light microscope
will most likely reveal
an abundance of which
inflammatory cells.
Okay, so think
about this.
And this is pus. I
hope you recognize
this is pus. And
pus is pyogenic or
purulent exudate
caused by usually
bacteria. and that would
be the major player
there would be
neutrophils. So the
answer is D as in
David neutrophils.
Okay that's the answer
here. The next case
question is a 19 year
old woman. She has a
five-day history of
fever up to 101. Sore
throat. She's been
tired and has difficulty
swallowing and they
do a physical. They
see generalized
lymphadenopathy. They probably
see a lot of other
things. I just shortened
the question. So
if she has a viral
infection, a CBC or a
complete blood count will
most likely show which
of the following.
Okay, this is a bit
trickier because
there are two correct
answers, as I have
mentioned in the
past, but one is the
better answer and
is the one you need
to go with. Okay,
so viral infection,
usually lymphocytes
will be increased.
So the answer again
is D as in David,
lymphocytosis. Now, B
is also correct, B as
in boy, because there
will be an increase
in white blood cell
count in general.
That's a general
thing. What we want to
get more specific here
is because the question
asked about viral,
so the answer is D.
And of course, leukopenia
means low white
cell count.
A seven-year-old
falls from his scooter
and injuries and
injures his ankle.
He becomes swollen,
red, painful.
Which of the following
is most responsible
for all three of
these consequences?
So again,
I happen to
like D a lot. D
as in David
is the answer.
Now all of these kind
of histamine nitric
oxide causes a swell
you know redness
and heat and it helps
with the vascular
permeability. Those
are all true and
selections and integrins
are involved in
the rolling and the
adhesion but bradykinin
if you remember
that chart we saw
it's very important for
pain but it also does
things like increased
vascular permeability
and vasodilates so
that's why D would be
acceptable in this
answer here's a summary
slide and of course the
lecture feedback form
please please reach me
by email or my office
is rockefellow306 on
Long Island campus.
And, you know,
if you have any
questions, don't
hesitate and do it sooner
rather than
later. Don't do it
near the exam. Try
to do it, you know,
as soon as you
have the question.
And I like to do
things in person. So if
you want to schedule
either an in-person
meeting or Zoom,
especially for those in
Arkansas, I like to do
that rather than write
you a long, long, long,
long email. So you
can just say, can
we schedule a Zoom?
Okay, this was a lot
of material and I want
to thank you very much
for your attention.